we'll take five topics and we'll drop a
beat to a freestyle so this this area
was where we've got a suggestion from
that from of alligator that was roundly
rejected to which I apologize but what
uh what would you like a rap about
plungers thank you so much have you
recently had a bathroom mishap yes uh
did you solve it
you just see your hands
sorry I asked about you said plunges so
I thought oh you had to clean out a
toilet so when I said have you recently
had a bathroom mishap you're like yeah
separate to that I [__] I love it that's
fantastic [__] your pants because
you don't have a plunger that's a thing
people you can people don't buy a
plunger until they need it that's the
problem with the plunger when you see
someone buying a plunger look how
they're walking uh I guarantee it will
be awkwardly wide need
so a plunger but [__] your pants
middle of the room you just put a hand
up here yes hello I mean look judging
from you you're so prim and proper
you're definitely not gonna say [__] in
my pants are you um what would you like
to rap about
my favorite person's least favorite
activity so that would be my wife she
despises camping she she finds she's
like we build houses wisely under canvas
um yeah some of you okay cool so my
favorite person my wife hating camping
thank you for it she'll be very upset
I'm talking about her on stage like this
there's a hand up in the middle as well
yes hello
I I heard something what was that
what was before City
bar
back
or bath yeah that's what you're saying
yeah okay cool thank you for the English
person for Translating that
what so when you're saying Bath City are
you talking about the the Roman Spanish
call it Bath City no one calls it that
did you go there and you're walking
around all America and being like I love
to be here about
ah look at this city that's adorable
thank you because in in the UK if you're
from the north you say bath if you're
from the south you say bath people from
bathrooms not a lot of Americans
ironic you're including yourself in that
group
um well I love it I will rap about bath
it's it's it's a lovely city and named
four what it was famous for so we have
the my wife camping [__] yourself
due to lack of pleasure but yes this is
a very female rap today I like this well
done boys because usually the boys are
just like big old dicks
thank you for restraining yourselves man
yes hello
um yeah the first time you've ever
spoken to a British person you have to
knock them in the eyes and greet them
the way they greet you hello
yeah yes what would you like a rap about
um working with special education
children
it would only be whoa if I was mean
about it
say this rap is negative this rap is
about what people suggesting to you what
was special education children yeah yeah
and you love you you love your job and
you love the children you work with so
that's what we're rapping about [__] all
of you who are like oh
inherently negative
you're bad people
um I guess let's get one more says
there's frat brothers so you both put
your hands up like this so I guess we'll
kind of I I will I will be the judges to
which one I will pick
um no no no no pressure it doesn't mean
it's better it's just no there's not I
said no pressure she's now stoking a
fight over here wearing a leather
they're both wearing leather jackets so
you're gonna lose because that is a
marker of gang affiliation
um we'll go with we'll go with you first
you have leather leather leather pants
so I was trying to speak like you
um
can I add leather pants into the
[__] yourself story that would be
quite nice I said what were you going to
suggest people who are really into maths
people who are really into Maps
cartographers yeah okay great also
people who like yeah yeah cool and then
Kendall Jenner lovely the way I know
nothing about celebrity culture the way
you gestures I was like is this Kendall
Jenner are you here
um I have no literally no idea
um okay Kendall Jenner is really into
match that was a perfect perfect
collaboration no no that's yeah yeah
just in case I'm not saying that it's
not slander please don't suit Me Kendall
Jenner
and I was into Maps that's a lie
okay so we have [__] yourself in
leather pants and a plunger my wife
camping bath working with special ed
you're so excited for the poorest
suggestion of the vibe
nothing special having children and
Kendall Jenner being really into maths
well this is a freestyle would you do me
a favor DJ and and press play
that's what rappers say isn't it press
play uh we've got quite a Soulful beat
for tonight I thought could we turn up a
little bit up here that'd be delightful
nice nice this is uh it's good I think
we'll start with yours your combined one
um just bear in mind I know very little
about the lady you mentioned
KJ yo facts I remember bring it out
looking at Maps that's Miss Jenna Kylie
another sisters with K but the Kendall
walks round the world this way and she
does it Opposite she feels like Magellan
so many maps come for so I know I'm
heading in the right direction
inspecting the scale because it's not
one to one if your eyesight fails then
you're struggling maybe get a map in
Braille the Contour she adores she's a
female
celebrity properly living in La the West
Case leather Jackie Laney she does save
her I see over there I took a little
glancer Scouts you see you're not the
jacket leather on the pants maybe he's
vegan and cow friendly if I wanna shoot
them it looks less frenzy I'm walking
around feeling not fried the opposite
shame but it just starts to slide why
because it's smooth not like corduroy
that will suck up all the [__] yeah you
know I do employ the leather it goes
smoothly like PVS
I know usually I excavate my bowels in
the toilet but someone blocked it up so
I really had to toil it was hard I
picked this up it was [__] like
thunder I mind this with the mic stand
as a plunger trying to suck a [__] out
the u-ben but I shot myself my wife
she's my best friend she was hating it
in the cold and down she says why the
[__] would you ever think we should
count that was a per day it's when I
learned this fact if I had a time
machine I would take it back I apologize
for bringing this for three days we took
a barbecue and mosquito spray still it
didn't work she really hated it the air
was fresh but there were Bears coming
round she was not impressed she likes
the featured Comfort At Last I took her
overseas UK we went a bar she had a
lovely time the best by far the hot
water coming up the Roman Spas that's
why it's named that it's famous for his
spring water coming up for the Romans
they saw to themselves they were like
exposing their nipples and then they
oiled themselves up it's called a
stridgel the tiny little stick that you
use on your skin that's the word that's
kind of hard for the kids to get in
their brain why because the situation
means they struggle with those words
special education but you've been doing
all the jobs people over here were like
oh those kids are odds well [__] you
yeah my teacher will tell feeling so
rewarded but you should go into hell she
helps them she teaches them get in all
the stencils drawing in Outside the
Lines it's not mental to love your job
and have fun with the kids over there
you guys what you did you're very cruel
you're horrible ah [__] you I hope you
[__] yourself
[Applause]
foreign